and in south america tonight an
environmental problem of a much greater
magnitude
the destructive structure destruction of
the amazon rainforest a worldwide
disaster
in the 1980s the world learned that the
amazon was in danger
trees are falling at a startling rate 77
000
square miles an area twice the size of
belgium the size of new york state the
size of california disappears
and why it was so important to save it
one-fifth the oxygen we breathe
20 half of the species of life on earth
is in these forms it's an ecosystem the
entire world
needs for its survival by the 1990s it
seemed like it was too late
the destruction accelerates more than
twice as fast as previously believed
virtually impossible to control once it
is gone
it is gone forever then something
changed
the annual destruction rate of the
amazon rainforest has dropped by 70
percent
the lowest rate of deforestation since
records began
amazon could retrieve the end of
deforestation huge accomplishment but in
order to keep it safe
there is one condition protecting the
forest is a continual process
brazil will need to stay vigilant
[Music]
but it didn't the amazon is burning
consumed by
fire fires have been raging thousands of
fires are blazing it's more and more
trees are cut down deforestation of the
amazon rainforest hit its highest rate
in a decade
today the amazon is being destroyed all
over again
the question is can it be saved this
[Music]
time
[Music]
the first wave of deforestation started
in the 1970s
that's when brazil's military regime saw
the potential for profit deep in the
amazon
there were about five million square
kilometers of rainforest
filled with natural resources amazonia's
wars and minerals food
fiber and forest resources are vast but
most of it was inaccessible
so the government started building the
trans-amazonian highway
an ambitious project that would run for
3 200 kilometers connecting remote parts
of the rainforest
at the time most of brazil's population
lived in the southeast
in cities like rio de janeiro and sao
paulo and the government wanted to move
people out here
to cultivate the land and grow the
economy so they offered free land along
the highway
and paid brazilians to settle deeper in
the rainforest and they sparked a land
rush
as the roads advanced settlers followed
rapidly clearing the forest around it
most of them turned their land into
pasture where they raised cows to sell
as beef and when these ranchers needed
more land
they seized another plot cleared it and
moved their cattle in
this expansion deeper into the amazon
drove up deforestation
between 1978 and 88 an average of over
20 000 square kilometers were cut down
each year
over time this whole area became known
as the arc of deforestation
and soon a different product pushed this
even further
people around the world were eating more
meat decade after decade
that trend raised the need for more
soybeans which served as a high protein
feed for farmed animals
this created a huge opportunity for
countries most suitable for growing
soybeans and brazil
cashed in soybean exports from brazil
shot up in the mid-90s boosting the
economy
by the early 2000s farmers took over
these pastures and turned them into
massive soy farms
like this one in akra statement
and the ranchers who sold their pastures
moved their cattle further into the
rainforest
clearing more of the amazon often
illegally this aggressive expansion
created a profitable pattern in
amazon
[Music]
[Music]
but it came at the cost of the
rainforest by the early 2000s brazil's
beef and soy industries were driving a
booming economy
as well as unprecedented rates of
deforestation
which caused this arc to expand further
north the staggering deforestation in
the amazon attracted fierce resistance
from
environmental groups an area of ancient
forest the size of a football field is
destroyed every two seconds
the brazilian government under president
lula
[Music]
she was brazil's environment minister in
2003 where she helped craft a plan to
stop deforestation
it started with the government expanding
the amount of rainforest under
protection
at the time only about 28 was protected
and there was very little oversight
but this new plan added more reserves
where business activities were strictly
banned
and also created more sustainable use
reserves where some businesses
like brazilian nut harvesting and rubber
tapping which didn't destroy the rain
forest were allowed
more land was also demarcated for
indigenous people who preserved the
forest
over time hundreds of new protected
lands were added transforming the amazon
into a shared and sustainable space
preservation
eventually almost half the amazon would
be put under some form of protection
while the rest of it remained a mix of
pasture farms and rainforests
to prevent further deforestation here
the government strengthened the forest
code
which said landowners could only clear
20 of their private land
this law was monitored by the forest
service which was part of the
environmental ministry which had
jurisdiction over all these protected
lands
and the key to enforcing this entire
plan was strengthening obama
a police agency that would track and
find people for illegal deforestation
and the plans showed results with
deforestation rates falling by more than
half
in 2006
[Music]
at the same time an activist movement
was forcing the agricultural industry to
make a change
major food companies started feeling
pressure from consumers for
participating in deforestation
so several got together and in 2006
signed a soy moratorium
which meant they could continue to
operate within existing farms
but they wouldn't buy soy from any newly
deforested land in the amazon
three years later beef companies signed
a similar agreement
other countries also gave brazil money
to help it protect the amazon
so under all this protection
deforestation rates plummeted to
historic lows
and yet brazil's soy and beef industries
continue to grow
thanks to more efficient techniques
ranchers started growing crops on their
existing pastures
and farmers planted two crops a year on
their land instead of one
brazil had found a way to make the
amazon both productive
and protected but there were some who
still wanted to be
a more profitable place
the ruralistas a group of conservative
politicians who represent the interests
of the agricultural industry
including farmers and ranchers started
gaining influence in brazil
in the early 2000s they had about 17 of
the seats in congress
but by 2012 they had about 30 enough
power to push president dilma rousseff
to weaken the force code which allowed
landowners to get away with clearing
more land
in 2016 they pushed president michel
temer to slash obama's budget
they also helped him pass a law that
made it easier for people who illegally
seized land the amazon
to keep it these changes emboldened some
people to seize and clear the rainforest
again
and that led to a rise in deforestation
rates
in 2018 as the rural leases controlled
44 percent of congress
jair bolsonaro a right-wing congressman
and allied to the ruralistas
was elected president
on his second day in office he
transferred the forest service which
monitors the force code
to the agricultural ministry led by
ruralista
he's also worked to systematically
weaken the environmental ministry
under bolsonaro deforestation has
increased significantly in 2019
most of it taking place in these
protected areas
setting fires is a common way to clear
land and in august 2019
over 30 000 fires were burning in the
amazon
three times as many as august 2018 many
set illegally by ranchers farmers and
landowners emboldened by the
government's new stance on the amazon
but this time the amazon is unlikely to
survive
another wave of deforestation
in the last 50 years it's estimated that
about 17
of the amazon has been deforested a 2018
report estimated that if it reaches 20
to 25
the whole rainforest could start to
collapse it wouldn't be enough to cycle
all the water it needs
causing trees to die and that would
release a huge amount of carbon dioxide
into the atmosphere
further warming the planet but in brazil
many politicians and agricultural
businesses continue to ignore the
science for the sake of profit
from
[Music]
clearing the amazon for short-term gains
overlooks the fact that the planet as we
know it
wouldn't exist without this rainforest
and it's why this place was saved
once before
[Music]
thanks for watching this special edition
of vox atlas it was one of three that we
produced on amazon
and this one was about the drivers of
deforestation and some of the brazilian
politics surrounding the current crisis
today
in the next one we're going to take a
step back into history we're going to
meet a man named chico mendes
who led the original fight to save the
amazon back in the 1980s
his story is super interesting and very
relevant for today
so make sure to come back and watch more
vox atlas and the amazon